cruise ships are Floating Death traps
with no laws that don't butt loads of
toxic waste into the ocean and pay
virtually no taxes despite making
millions of dollars every single week
let me explain
so you want to get into the booming
business of travel people crave
exploring new places and they're willing
to pay top dollar for the pleasure and
there are a ton of different ways to
approach it you can start a tourism
company invest in a fancy hotel maybe
even start a souvenir store or bar but
the problem with all these things is
that they're just one-off opportunities
to get more money out of gullible
tourists they come in they eat sleep or
buy once and then they just leave taking
all their vacation money somewhere else
that's why if you really want to rack up
the most money in the travel industry
you need to invest in a cruise ship this
is satire not Financial advice
one cruise ship can make you more money
in a single year than 15 different
luxury hotels combined think about it
cruise ships can carry over 6 500 people
on them almost double the capacity of
some of the biggest hotels on the planet
each of those passengers are paying a
couple hundred to a couple thousand
dollars to just get onto the ship in the
first place that's over a million
dollars in Revenue before the boat has
even left the port they board your
cruise ship for a week or more and on
the vessel well they're gonna need to
spend money on food drinks massages
recreational activities souvenirs
they're gonna want to gamble and guess
what you own a monopoly on all of it you
get to capture every single Cent they
spend you can even charge 75 cents per
minute for Wi-Fi and the passengers will
just have to suck it up bend over and
take it leading each passenger to spend
almost a hundred dollars per day on all
this tantalizing stuff after you account
for all your expenses you're walking
away with around 291 dollars in profit
per passenger or in other words you're
taking home 239 thousand dollars every
single day at Sea do you see how
powerful this is
[Music]
cruise ships are such an attractive
pitch that they pull in over 13 million
passengers every single year but as
passengers embark on a cruise for a fun
easy escape from their everyday lives
little do they know that they're
supporting one of the sickest most
destructive Industries in the entire
world deaths disappearance is sickness
you name it cruise ships have it
so stay dangerous subscribe for more and
this is the evil industry of cruise
ships
[Music]
and if you want some free stocks you can
get up to 12 free stocks when you sign
up for Weeble and deposit any amount
with the link below you can literally
deposit as little as one cents and
you'll still get the free stocks this
promotion definitely isn't going to last
forever their last promotions didn't so
you're going to want to claim it as soon
as possible with the link below by
opening an account you're automatically
going to get two free stocks each valid
between three dollars and 300 and then
you'll receive another four or eight or
ten free stocks value between seven and
three thousand dollars after you make an
initial deposit of any amounts and if
you're new to Weeble You're Gonna Want
to get an account set up as soon as
possible before the next bull market
comes so you can be ready to plunder
Weeble is a Great Commission free stock
training app they allow you to invest
with as little as five dollars thanks to
fractional shares where you can own a
fraction of a stock without committing
to a whole share and they even have a
paper trading feature where you can hone
in your skills on a stock trading
simulator without putting real money on
the line this is great if you're a
beginner you don't have enough funds yet
you have the capital but don't know
where to start or if you want to test
new trading strategies so get up to fall
free Stocks by pausing the video and
clicking the link below pause the video
and click the link below the claim now
thanks to Weeble for sponsoring this
video
[Music]
let's rewind
before Cruise became the money hungry
billion dollar industry they are today
shifts were the only way to cross the
oceans back in the 1800s you know like
how the Titanic was supposed to go but
for the whole Iceberg thing
at the time the only people who could
afford a ship were the ultra wealthy
people like Royal princes authorities
and Nobles but as word spread around
more rich people wanted to hitch a ride
on these ships so the industry started
building them bigger and more luxurious
to accommodate their Rich clientele it
went on like this for over a hundred
years but then the 1960s came welcome
aboard welcome aboard the spacious cabin
attractively decorated air-conditioned
but draft free commercial airplanes they
were faster easier sleeker more modern
they were just simply a better way to
travel so the cruise ship industry was
faced with an existential crisis they
were losing all their customers fast so
if they didn't come up with a way to
make people want to ride on cruise ships
again even though planes were clearly a
better option they were gonna sink so
the industry completely rebranded cruise
ships for nearly two decades we have
endeavored to bring to our passengers a
cruise experience that is both uniquely
satisfying and totally
now ships weren't just a way to get to a
destination cruise ships were the
destinations themselves they transformed
cruises from purely being a method of
transportation to an exciting experience
and it worked like a charm the other
major change the industry made was that
cruises weren't just for rich people
anymore they were for everyone and the
industry was making more money than it
ever had before but as fun and exciting
as they appear there are a ton of dark
things happening behind the scenes that
go into making these high energy
profitable cruises happen things that
the industry really don't want you to
know about
foreign
first there's the sewage
having thousands of people confined to a
shift for a week or more means there's
going to be thousands of tons of human
waste that cruise ships need to dispose
of that's around 10 swimming pools worth
of waste by the end of a week-long
voyage and you may think that there
would be strict rules about how to
handle all this extremely toxic waste
but you would be wrong all Cruises have
to do is be 12 miles out at Sea and
they're allowed to dump all the stuff
right into the ocean think about that
next time you're taking a dip in the sea
it's not just really disgusting it's
also genuinely bad for the environments
and this is just the stuff that cruise
ships are legally allowed to do there's
also a lot of illegal things cruise
ships have committed Carnival's Princess
Cruises will pay a 40 million dollar
fine for dumping oily waste into the
ocean it is the largest penalty of its
kind in history the company also pleaded
guilty to seven felony charges the
world's largest cruise company has
pleaded guilty to violating the terms of
its probation just two years after it
was found purely guilty of environmental
crimes aside from polluting the ocean
cruise ships are also really good at
polluting the air we breathe the amount
of pollution emitted by a luxury liner
equals that of 5 million cars covering
the same distance to put that into
perspective there are about 3.6 million
drivers in New York city so every single
cruise ship is putting out one and a
half times the size of New York City
pollution on every single trip there are
323 ships on the ocean all the time and
they're all polluting the air that much
every single day that's a lot of
pollution cruise ships also use an
especially destructive type of fuel to
power their ships it's called heavy fuel
oil it's so heavy that it's like tar and
it just it's life span is just years and
years and years and then the other
impact is when you and it burns it burns
dirty it's highly viscous and when
combusted to generate the power to
propel vessels generates enormous
quantities of Highly toxic gases and
they're not using a little dab of this
heavy fuel either the average cruise
ship uses 1 500 tons of heavy fuel every
single day every single day you know
that giant black cloud that comes out of
the top of cruise ships everywhere they
go yeah and that heavy fuel oil being
burned off and all of that is going into
your lungs it was an environmental group
that now says time on board a cruise
ship could be bad for your health air
quality is just as bad or even worse
they say than some of the world's most
polluted cities but the air pollution
will be the least of your worries when
you're on a cruise
[Music]
if you were unlucky enough to be on a
cruise ship when covet hit then you are
practically guaranteed a positive test
that's because cruise ships have always
been a breeding ground for disease it's
actually a recurring issue cruise ships
are often nicknamed floating Petri
dishes for just how common outbreaks
occur on board and it makes sense cruise
ships can find thousands of different
people altogether in an unfamiliar
environment with new food and unusual
germs all from foreign countries yum
so if one person gets the bug they are
all getting it There Is No Escape there
are a ton of different things you can
catch on a cruise but the most common is
a norovirus outbreak Royal Caribbean's
Oasis of the Seas got to Port Canaveral
here at four o'clock this morning and
you can see passengers are still
disembarking as they describe to me
their experience being on board the ship
after hundreds get sick of suspected
norovirus what involves vomiting and
diarrhea norovirus outbreaks spread
through close contact and contaminated
surfaces which make them perfect for
cruises the CDC reported that almost 1
in 10 passengers contracted a
gastrointestinal illness on cruise ships
between 2008 and 2014. those are not
very good odds for passengers paying
thousands of dollars but hey at least it
will make for a memorable vacation
thank you
one of the best things about the cruise
ship industry is that you pay virtually
zero taxes Yes you heard that right
almost zero dollars to the tax man so if
you've been looking for a business to
start that's practically tax-free but
starting a religion isn't your thing
here's what you gotta do step one
acquire a cruise ship unlike most
businesses that must operate in a single
location cruise ships do their business
out on the Open Seas that gives you a
lot more wiggle room when it comes to
your tax jurisdiction enough wiggle room
to still operate out of U.S ports so you
can get the money out of the Americans
all without having to pay any U.S taxes
on those profits Step 2 register your
ship in a foreign country every ship on
the planet is required by international
law to register with the country and fly
the flag of that place out on sea but
who said that place had to be the US
according to a 100 euro tax code cruise
ships are able to register in a country
that have much more hands-off laws in
the US it's called flying a flag of
convenience that's why you even though
ninety percent of cruise ship companies
do business in the US they fly the flags
of other countries this magical
exemption allows cruise ships to pay an
average tax rate of 0.8 percent even
though every other us Corporation is
taxed at 21 step number three sit back
and let the profits roll in the US
government has set cruise ships up
perfectly to make as much money as they
want off of Americans without paying the
country a dime in taxes plus bonus
points since your ship is registered in
a small country within a net government
like Panama or Liberia you're also not
confined to all those pesky U.S
employment laws you can hire workers
from all over the world and pay them
next to nothing for working 12 hours a
day seven days a week the average cruise
ship worker makes around 1.62 to 2.27
cents per hour that is pretty insane
you're making billions while only having
to pay your laborers a couple dollars an
hour with almost zero taxes this is the
best business ever and while you're not
paying taxes you can still utilize U.S
taxpayer-funded Services whenever a
disease outbreak happens on board or a
ship gets caught in a storm and needs
rescue or a passenger Falls overboard
it's the US government that must step in
and help one of these rescue missions
costs over eight hundred thousand
dollars and it all came out of U.S taxes
but the lawlessness gets much darker
than just taxes and labor there's also
the deaths and disappearances
you're misunderstanding me bro
[Music]
the morning hours of March 24 1998 the
Bradley family awoke to a nightmare on
their Royal Caribbean International
Cruise the family's 23 year old daughter
Amy was missing an All-American Girl
vanishes from a Caribbean cruise liner
somebody saw her somebody wanted her and
somebody took her it seemed impossible
it only been a few hours since her
family saw her last and everything
seemed fun and they were all the way out
in the middle of the open ocean so where
could she had possibly gone her family
didn't waste a second and immediately
alerted their cruise ship's crew begging
them to show a photo of Amy to the other
passengers and to secure the exes at the
next stop anything that might help find
their daughter but the crew wasn't
having it they weren't gonna show her
photo and they definitely work in a hot
the cruises itinerary the crew was too
worried it would disturb the other
guests and their profits all they said
they could do was search around the
common areas and bathrooms as quietly as
possible the cruise went on as usual and
the passengers vacation went undisturbed
and yet Amy Lynn Bradley is still miss
to this day 25 years later her family
still believes that they could have
found her if the cruise ship treated the
situation more seriously Amy's story is
sad but it isn't rare hundreds of people
have become victims of violent crimes on
cruise ships or they just disappeared
altogether never to be seen again on the
left pictured with her sister this is 24
year old Rebecca corium a girl from
Chester seeing the world and now lost at
sea 5000 miles from home son boarded a
Royal Caribbean ship for his honeymoon
and he never got off we'll go on to that
mysterious death of a cruise ship on a
cruise ship the FBI is investigating
after authorities say a 39 year old
woman died on board a Princess cruise
ship in Alaska following a domestic
dispute crimes and disappearances on
cruise ships are an epidemic nearly 170
people have disappeared on cruise ships
since 1995 and there's good reason why
it's so common it's because there are
virtually no loss or systems of Justice
once you set sail on the cruise ship yup
that's right if you ever need to take
some one out without getting caught just
invite them onto a cruise and you're
good to go that's the thing about being
in international waters international
waters the land that love forgot hope is
thousands of miles away so the people
who respond to all the crimes on the
cruise ship are completely unqualified
Cruise Line security guards who are
obviously on the side of the cruise line
not the passengers we're going to be out
on open ocean no laws just us and our
tasty treats and even when the case is
eventually investigated it's done by the
country where the ship is registered
which again is usually a tiny country
with an enough government with no budget
that is thousands of miles away from
where the crime occurred so if you are a
loved one because a victim of a crime on
a cruise ship it would be the law
enforcement of places like Panama or the
Bahamas investigating it if you're an
American the FBI can choose a step in
but even then they usually don't arrive
until long after crucial evidence is
gone it's an impossible situation for
law enforcement and an absolutely
perfect scenario for creeps thieves and
murderers to do anything they want
that's why crime is is absolutely
rampant on cruises and why most of these
cases never get solved and yet despite
all this millions of people still sign
up like lands for Slaughter every single
year to take a ride on them and it seems
like there is not an end in sight for
this industry even after coven the
cruise ship industry is still just too
powerful after 60 years of unmitigated
rain they're too rich after all these
tax-free decades and cruise lines have
been reinvesting that money into
lobbying the US government to keep
things just the way they are they spent
66 million dollars in lobbying between
1998 and 2019 and thanks to lots of
special donations to Canada's in cruise
ship States these candidates fight on
their behalf to block Cruise taxes and
there's no system in place to force
rules against them anyways cruise ships
are like their own little floating
nation and the governments of these
nations go by the names of Carnival
Norwegian and Royal Caribbean
the fact that cruises found a way to
only pay their slaves I mean laborers
one and a half to two and a half dollars
an hour while they rake in billions is
not that surprising if you watch this
channel take a look at the Fortune 500
list pretty much all of them had to find
some way to exploit modern day slavery
to ever be able to scale to their size
for cruise ships it was this for a show
it was by exploiting Nigeria for Nike is
sweatshops in Asia and so on and so
forth so if you're looking to get into
business you are gonna need to
understand this if you don't want to get
stuck at the size of a small business
and lucky for you I expose all of it in
financial slavery Master Class Financial
slavery masterclass is the course that
says what powerful people are too afraid
to say out loud it exposes how slavery
never went away it just changed forms
and it slipped right under everyone's
noses and most importantly it breaks
down how you can apply all the stuff
today right now so that you can Ascend
the ladders of money and power I believe
that education should be as entertaining
as a Netflix series that's why you're
gonna get taught all the stuff other
binge-worthy documentary style lessons
that are just as entertaining as these
videos that you come to love which is
why I can confidently say that there has
never been such a ballsy course like
this ever made and you can watch the
first lesson for free right now with the
link below trust me if you enjoy these
videos you are gonna love this first
free lesson and all the other lessons
are just as entertaining there's a 14
day no questions asked refund policy
just email us and you can also earn
around a hundred dollars for every
person you refer to the master class as
well so scroll down click the link at
the top of the description or in the
pinned comment and watch the first
lesson for free right now
[Music]
thank you